How's the app coming along?
>> It's going along really great.
Our students just
reached a big milestone.
They were able to add all the vocabulary
words you gave us into the app.
>> Wow,
it's really starting to take shape.
>> I'm glad you like it.
What should we do next?
>> I think our students are ready
to add images to the app now.
We could have our designer
create illustrations for us.
Andrea, do you have any ideas for
images we could use?
>> Yes.
For
the number words, I was thinking
we could use acorns since they're
significant in the Mewar culture.
>> What do they stand for?
>> They used to be
a staple food source but
now they're a symbol for
connecting the past and the present.
I was thinking we can use one acorn for
one, two for the number two and so on.
>> Ooh, I really like that idea.
So that takes care of
the numbers category.
Now what about the colors?
>> What if we just use
the plain color and
put it like in a circle or something.
>> Yeah, I think we should use
the colors in a list item.
>> I agree.
>> What about family members?
>> I have a good one for those.
We can use pictures of my family.
>> Cool, thanks so
much for bringing these.
I think this is going to add
a really personal touch to the app.
>> I really like all these ideas.
What about our final category, phrases?
>> I can't think of any
images we can use for those.
>> How about we just don't use images
then because there's no clear visual
that people would easily recognize.
>> All right, I like that.
So that takes care of
all our categories.
>> And
after they add in all those images,
we should do some visual improvements
in the app because right now,
the category screen is
looking a little plain.
>> Yeah, we can definitely do that.
We can change up the colors,
change the font sizes,
and then maybe add some
padding to the list items?
>> Yeah, that will make it
look a lot more polished.
I can't wait to see it next time.
>> Let's revisit our course map.
Right now,
we're in lesson three out of four, so
to provide you with more detail on what
we're going to accomplish in the lesson.
First, we're going to add
images to the app and
then we're going to display
the correct images for
each word in the list and lastly, we're
going to add visual polish to the app.